[Music]
foreign
if you've asked Alexa Siri or Google
Assistant for something you've used
artificial intelligence already but open
ai's chat GPT has taken things to a new
level though even that AI is still
narrow Auto GPT can in some
circumstances take chat GPT to a new
level and execute machine-based tasks
for you but we're not at a point where
an AI powered device or machine can
think abstractly to solve things at
least not yet and some of the minds
behind the current versions of AI we
have are worried we're not that far off
the fact that we don't know how much
time we have left is itself not a good
sign that we have any idea what we're
doing and we would start capping things
now ai researcher eleazarudkowski says
we should stop trying to make AI better
and smarter you know gpt4 is pretty
interesting we just capped it out of
gpt4 we could get a whole lot of
interesting stuff out of that we could
maybe make an exception for you know
medical research type AIS like Alpha
full that don't have the same kind of
General thinking ability as gbt4 and are
nonetheless capable of doing like very
useful stuff and like you know and then
not push those too far either he says
even if we don't have international
agreements in place even with our
adversaries on AI use it still needs to
be regulated a new Fox News poll finds
just about half of us are familiar with
new AI technology like GPT and those who
are familiar with it are slightly more
likely to say it's a good thing rather
than a bad thing but either way an
overwhelming number of poll respondents
want regulations on AI and most of us
don't think government is up to the task
now a White House official has confirmed
a Fox News the vice president is meeting
tomorrow with the heads of alphabet
anthropic openai and Microsoft to
discuss ethical AI Innovation there are
still things that we can do Tristan
Harris is co-founder of the center for
Humane technology and a former Google
ethicist did we completely contain
nuclear weapons no there have been
several that have run loose but we did
collect limited to nine countries we did
create the nuclear Test Ban Treaty and
those things with regard to nuclear
technology I think are important because
they point to you know you could have
been sitting here in 1945 and you could
have had Oppenheimer and Richard Feynman
and Enrico Fermi and some of the atomic
scientists saying you know we regret the
creation that we made with the atomic
bomb and we don't see a way this is
going to end well in some of the nuclear
scientists committed suicide believing
that they wouldn't be able to contain it
and yet we are here we're still here
right now but we're not here because of
just fortune and luck although there is
some of that we're also here because a
lot of people work really hard to figure
out how do we deal with this new kind of
power can we Steward this power without
destroying ourselves
and I think what you're finding and
there's this big letter that came out
you know a month ago the pause letter
for AI and you know some people they
anchored that to Elon Musk because he
was one of the signatories although he
joined later in that process important
to note about that letter is it's the
founders of the field of artificial
intelligence Jeffrey Hampton just left
Google as you said who's kind of one of
the fathers of neural networks but
yahshua vengo who's one of the fathers
of deep learning and Stuart Russell who
wrote The Textbook on artificial
intelligence these people all signed
this letter because they say that there
are major existential risks here and if
there's that many credible people who
literally created this field I think
it's very important that we have a very
clear eye debate and discussion really
about what is of existential risk here
and if it is a suicide race and no one
wants that literally no one wants our
you know everyone to just disappear from
getting this wrong if that's novel we
want
how do we coordinate
when you see the race among the tech
companies right and you hear about also
some of the tech world's layoffs
Microsoft let go what an entire ethics
team maybe not everybody in ethics but
certainly quite a few people yep as we
talk and we put the burden in on
Congress when it comes to regulations
what burden should be on that the tech
companies you just referenced several
people in the tech world who are calling
for a stop but when you look at the
companies that are sort of pushing this
and racing against each other what is
the burden in your mind on one
well I think a lot of people inside the
companies feel trapped because as you
said there's now a market race to
release right and when openai and Sam
Altman you know fired the starting gun
and said we are going to ship this as
part of chat GPT uh and ship it to the
world and it's important for listeners
to know that it took four and a half
years for Facebook to reach 100 million
users it took Tick Tock nine months to
reach 100 million users it took chat gbt
less than two months to reach 100
million users so the rate in which we
are deploying this technology is faster
than anything of this kind of
consequence and moreover we're not just
sort of putting up a website and saying
here's this blinking cursor this AI you
can talk to open AI for example has
created an API a platform that basically
developers can include chatgpt directly
into all of their products and they're
not testing this right and this isn't
because they're evil CEOs or bad people
it's because the speed at which the you
know clock rate of this industry has
been set by market forces and
specifically by a handful of decisions
about a year ago that said hey we're
going to start releasing this stuff to
the public it's important to note that
Google and deepline for example have
very sophisticated Advanced AI
capabilities that they have been holding
back because they don't feel like
they're safe or ready for society to
have yet and that was a wise thing to do
that's the world that we should be
living in and I think what's happened is
that now the companies are caught in
this race that really was sort of
accelerated by open AIS you know I think
really I mean one can say Reckless you
know decision to release this stuff as
fast as possible no they'll push back on
that and say you know we had gbt4 for
example that we were testing for safety
for more than eight months and we should
celebrate that they did that that's the
negative space that we can't see is
everybody who is holding back their
capabilities but overall now that it's
released now that it's out there we are
seeing all the gloves come off and all
the companies are now racing to push
this out there as fast as possible so
now when I talk to people who are inside
the company they don't want that in fact
they feel deeply uncomfortable that we
cannot at this pace get this right and
this is why Jeff Hinton kind of one of
the Godfathers of AI who just left
Google left is he said it's not about
what the capabilities are right now it's
the speed and the exponential curve at
which these things are going I want to
ask you about regulation
um if we're if we're looking to the
government to do this and and the stakes
are different right and they haven't
been able to come up with regulations on
social media as you know you've seen all
the hearings right that's right
um are the stakes different enough that
this time is different and the pressure
is different and if China doesn't agree
to the same set of regulations or any
adversary doesn't agree to the same set
of regulations how do we regularly our
own use of AI to still remain
competitive
so these are some great questions
there's a few that you just laid out
here so I want to take them kind of one
by one one is around as you said we have
not regulated social media we're now 10
years into the crisis around how it's
warped our politics and broken mental
health and shortened attention spans and
not been healthy for our democracy and
yet we haven't done anything now why
haven't we done something we waited
until social media became irrevocably
entangled with our society and once it
became entangled think about how hard it
is to ban Tick Tock which is this is an
easy choice this is a Chinese Communist
Party influenced company who's basically
running the Telecommunications
infrastructure and Saturday morning
cartoons of its number one geopolitical
adversary it would be like letting the
Soviet Union run television programming
for the U.S during the Cold War and so
one of the things that is different to
your point with AI is that it is not yet
entangled this is actually why we were
raced to create this presentation called
the AI dilemma that I do recommend for
as many of your listeners who are
capable of watching it just Google for
AI dilemma we really put it together in
a way to say look we're at the moment
before entanglement not everything in
our society is entangled with these new
artificial general intelligence
um you know open AI jet GPT type
language models it's not embedded in
everything yet and if we're going to
regulate it we have to do it now not
after one thing to note is that the
people who build AGI these artificial
general intelligence companies companies
like deepmind open AI you know and
Google the people who started these
companies they would have been aware of
the existential risks of AI since the
very beginning unlike social media where
Mark Zuckerberg didn't say now if we
build this this might ruin society and
democracy he didn't have that thought
but all literally every single one of
the AI company CEOs have known about the
fact that there are existential risks
for Humanity since the beginning now
let's be honest um China is racing to
AGI as fast as possible they have said
that they do not view the US in
Cooperative terms in terms of AI
um I think that's a mistake for both
parties the US is similarly racing to
AGI as fast as possible but the question
is if you're racing to a technology that
you and the people who build it don't
believe you can control
um as I mentioned in this yeah I just
love my presentation there's a survey of
about 700 AI researchers that was the
largest survey that we know that's been
done to date on this asking people what
is the chance that Humanity uh goes
extinct or similarly disempowered from
our inability to control Ai and 50 of
the researchers half of the researchers
said there's a 10 percent or greater
chance that we go extinct from our
inability to control AI now that's be
like getting on a plane where 50 of the
people who made that 737 you're about to
board say you know there's a 10 chance
that our inability to control This Plane
means that it goes down
so that's a number that we should have a
democratic conversation say we shouldn't
onboard Humanity onto that plane now
that doesn't mean that China's plane is
safer either by the way right
it's not like their plane is also
magically a lot safer this is a
fundamentally uncontrollable technology
of large language models I won't go into
details but we're better off cooperating
to get to something than we are
competing now I know that might sound
incredibly naive to anybody especially
with the national security background
um and believe me we actually talk to
people in National Security and take
those concerns incredibly seriously but
I think we have to be incredibly
clear-eyed about the risks here because
you know if I was trying to I would see
the United States racing to AGI right
now and deploying it everywhere is
actually unsafe for the entire world
because it's not about the race to you
know get plutonium it's about the race
to harness plutonium in a safe way and
not have loose facile material that
anybody can build weapons with and right
now we're releasing AI in a way in the
US at least that is racing to deploy
plutonium to everybody as fast as
possible but not actually having the
safety controls and I think the the race
isn't to get to AGI the race is to
harness AI safely and we should both
countries really agree on that
um just a couple more for you uh house
speaker Kevin McCarthy setups and panels
for lawmakers of both parties as you
know with two AI experts from MIT that
seems on its face like a pretty good
idea right if you're going to regulate
this thing you're going to have the
conversation you should probably hear
from some real experts some real
computer scientists
um what what else would you tell
lawmakers to do or read or watch other
than you know the AI dilemma of your own
production well I think I think it's
great that Kevin McCarthy convened um
you know these AI Tech leaders to to
brief lawmakers what I worry about is
who's in the room I worry about just
because you have a computer science
background or a technical background or
an AI background does not mean you
understand the interaction effects with
Society I found this with social media
right I had you know I met some of the
smartest people I'd ever met in the
world at Google and at Facebook and at
these you know YouTube these companies
building these Advanced systems and I
think there's a bias that when you meet
really smart people that they're
therefore going to know on the
engineering side that they're going to
know suddenly how it's going to affect
teenagers 10 years from now you know
just because you understand the
technology doesn't mean you understand
the interaction effects with Society
it's not intrinsic to social media that
it would unravel society and democracy
it was that the incentives in the race
that it was designed against which is to
get maximum engagement to get attention
which means shorter bite-sized forms of
attention more extreme you know
political take cynical views on
everything go more viral than good faith
interpretations of what people are doing
and that was enough to unravel society
and that had to do with social
psychological effects of a technology
and society and what I want for
lawmakers is to be briefed by people who
are really focusing on the interaction
effects with society and the ways that
it can cause existential risks
and I worry that this is happening too
fast for our institutions to deal with
and we have a very short time window if
you think about how fast this field
moves compared to other fields the son
Harris Center for Humane technology
thank you so much for joining us so good
to be here with you thank you so much